I
self-consciousness found the thing to be
like itself and itself to be like a
thing that is it is aware that it is in
itself the objectively real world it is
no longer the immediate certainty of
being all reality but a certainty for
which the immediate in general has the
form of something superseded so that the
objectivity of the immediate still has
only the value of something superficial
its inner being an essence being self
consciousness itself the object to which
it is positively related is therefore a
self consciousness it is in the form of
thing hood that is it is independent but
it is certain that this independent
object is for it not something alien and
thus it knows that it is in principle
recognized by the object it is spirit
which in the duplication of its
self-consciousness and in the
independence of both has the certainty
of its unity with itself this certainty
now has now to be raised to the level of
truth what holds good for it in
principle and in its inner certainty has
to enter into its consciousness and
become explicit for it
here in paragraph 347 we are now
entering into a new subsection of this
massive reason portion of the
phenomenology we have finished up with
observing reason which is is great we've
progressed through all of that there's a
lot of very interesting material in
there but in my view at least the
material that's yet to come is yet more
interesting and this is one of the most
interesting sections of the rest of the
work so now we're moving into subsection
B of the reason portion which is called
the actualization of rational self
consciousness through its own activity
it's quite a mouthful there what are we
actually talking about well the
actualization the you know making itself
real making itself view click actual in
the world of rational self consciousness
of what it is that's been driving this
entire process I'm self-consciousness
your self consciousness Hagel himself is
a self consciousness now through its own
activity that if you look ahead you're
going to see that there are three
subsections to this subsection the first
is pleasure and necessity and then we
get this this really interesting
discussion about it's couched in terms
of the law of the heart and the frenzy
of self-conceit and then we finish up by
getting to this this discussion of
virtue and the way of the world and
there's some brilliant dialectical work
going on there we'll talk much more
about that as we get into those those
subsections for now we're at a very
important transition point and what I've
got here on the board is supposed to
represent a bit of that and we're just
sort of stepping now into the
new edifice we're stepping out of the
passageway of the earlier section and
into the new one so he begins where he
left off in the previous paragraph
self-consciousness found the thing to be
like itself and itself to be like a
thing now we've seen this before we saw
this in the self-consciousness section
didn't we so we're going to see this
developed now in a new way he says it's
aware that it is in itself the
objectively real world again a theme
that we saw as soon as we began
exploring the reason section even before
we got to observing reason as such and
then especially once we got into the
very first part of observing reason
reason is the totality of what it is
that self-consciousness can have
presented to it can be aware of so he
says it's no longer the immediate
certainty of being all reality but a
certainty for which the immediate in
general has the form of something
superseded so that the objectivity of
the immediate still has only the value
of something superficial its inner being
in essence being self consciousness
itself here we have this this diagram
now that I've put on board which you may
find very useful so we have self
consciousness should be there we go on
the one side and we have the thing the
actual the objective is we're saying in
the previous Paris the dead thing on the
other and we're no longer now talking
about you know spirit and skulls or
stuff like that we left that behind now
we're dealing with a much more general
point self consciousness is connected at
first in a sort of immediate
relationship of certainty with the thing
what thing well it could be understood
as the totality of what appears to it
could be understood as a particular
thing that it is centered on or a set of
things it doesn't really matter what
individual thing we're talking about
here in part because there's going to be
such an important transition now Hagel
says that we've moved from the immediate
certainty right of being all existence
or being all things to something
superseded something across in German
alcohol burn and this is you know the
verbal form of Alf hey bong this
transition to something that is is
greater something that integrates
something that that leaves behind d'etre
test but picks up the outlines or the
the essential framework of what is has
been superseded right and Hagel is going
to talk here about the need to move as
we've seen so many other times from
certainty towards truth certainty by
itself is not truth if its height is not
the same thing as truth and so now we're
going to move towards that how is that
going to happen well this has to do with
what the thing is the thing turns out to
be self consciousness its inner being
and essence being self consciousness
itself so he goes on and he says the
object to which it that is the first
self consciousness is positive
positively related is therefore a
self-consciousness and here we're going
to see the dialectic of self and other
repeated again but taken to a higher
level and this is going to happen over
and over again this is the grand sweep
of what we call spirit diced so he goes
on and he says it is in the form of
thing hood it is independent so this
thing hood has a double meaning to it
when we when we grasp another as
and other self consciousness and we
grasp them as being like ourselves we as
we've seen already that doesn't mean
that they're exactly like ourselves or
that we can completely predict what it
is that they're going to do because they
are self-conscious they are something
else that has an inner spontaneity that
has a reflexive relation to self that
can act that can in fact become the pole
which is the primary pole by which we
end up ourselves being turned into the
thing the object being objectified so
all of this is involved at the beginning
here implicitly and Hagel is going to
draw out explicitly what is going on so
he says it is in the form of thing hood
it is independent but it is certain that
this independent object is for it not
something alien and thus that it is it
knows that it is in principle recognized
by the object you remember the dialectic
of recognition that was driving not only
the struggle to the death but also the
master-slave dialectic and then running
throughout in a subterranean way the
dialectic of Stoicism skepticism and the
unhappy consciousness that now is going
on here in this section so he says it is
spirit which in the duplication of its
self-consciousness and in the
independence of both has the certainty
of its unity with itself so spirit is
you might say in a certainly a third
term getting put into the mix but it's
not a third term that's existing
independently of these other two terms
the other self consciousnesses and Hagel
is is doing something here that the bit
abstract but we can make sense of this
by thinking about our concrete
relationships that we have with other
people and in terms of a world in which
we have purposive activity and
motivations and a history going on so he
goes on and he brings us to a close
saying this certainty as I mentioned
before has now to be raised to the level
of truth what holds good for it in
principle and in its inner certainty has
to enter into its consciousness and
become explicit for it so what does that
mean that means that this this process
of being something superseded is not yet
finished and there's going to be some
further development of the self
consciousness in relation to the world
of things but in relation to the world
of things that are things for and
through other self consciousness
what the general stages of this
actualization will be is readily
apparent in a general way from a
comparison with the path hitherto
followed just as reason in the role of
observer repeated in the element to the
category the movement of consciousness
that is sent certainty perception and
the understanding so will reason again
run through the double movement of
self-consciousness and pass over from
Independence into its freedom to begin
with this active reason is aware of
itself merely as an individual and as
such must demand and produce its reality
in and other then however its
consciousness having raised itself into
universality it becomes Universal reason
and is conscious of itself as reason as
a consciousness that has already
recognized in and for itself which in
its pure consciousness unites all
self-consciousness it is the simple
spiritual essence which in attaining
consciousness is at the same time real
substance into which the earlier forms
return as into their ground so that in
comparison with the latter they are
merely particular moments in it's
becoming moments which do indeed break
loose and appear as independent forms
but in fact have existence and reality
only is grounded in that becoming and
possess their truth only insofar as they
are and remain in it
Hagel is not quite yet showing his hand
here in paragraph 348 what he's saying
is again still rather abstract and if
you were to stop right here you wouldn't
completely understand where he is going
to be going as he's going to show us in
the next paragraph which may hit you as
a bit of a jolt what he's doing here is
he's talking about how what is about to
come in this new section of reason is in
fact this this sub elation of what has
happened in the previous sections not
only of reason but also of consciousness
and of self-consciousness the entire
work up until this point minus of course
the preface and the introduction so he
says the general stages of this
actualization of this becoming actual
right fork self-consciousness what the
general stages will be is readily
apparent in a general way from a
comparison with the path followed up
until this point so he says remember
back we had sent certainty and then we
had perception and of course you know
deception and the thing and then we had
finally had the understanding and forces
world's laws all this this interesting
stuff the supersensible well that was
the movement of consciousness and
observing reason has he says retraced
this this movement of consciousness if
you think about what happened in the
observing reason section we started out
with you know pretty simple stuff the
inorganic and then we got the organic
and that threw us for a bit of a loop
and we had to introduce new categories
like that of the end and teleology and
then I started getting even more complex
when we got to psychological and logical
laws and then we have the entire
physiognomies infra knology section very
much focused on human action and you
know by the end of it what we're still
doing is what the others
is attempting to try to find laws right
so all of that is going to be taken up
and it's been reworked in a new way and
observing reason and now in this new
section he says we're going to retrace
what happened in the self-consciousness
section he says reason again is going to
run through the double movement of
self-consciousness and pass over here's
his summarization right pass over from
independence into its freedom now that
is you know we're representing that here
schematically it's just an arrow
pointing from independence and the
freedom you remember how long that
section was and how many transformations
were required and the fact that we kept
on dealing with duality and a redoubling
of itself and a projection of itself out
there ultimately into the the eternal
the beyond of the unhappy consciousness
all of that is is being sort of
collapsed for the moment into this but
all of that is going to be replayed now
again alcohol burn sub lated raised to a
higher level in what is happening with
reason no longer observing reason but
now reason actualizing itself through
its own activity and in progressive
stages so he goes on and he says it to
begin with this active reason is aware
of itself merely is an individual we
left off by talking about the role of
the individual as we finished up the
observing reason section we've been
trying to make sense out of individuals
and indeed individuality and trying to
derive some general laws some universals
that would work for that now the
observing individual has become
conscious of itself particularly as an
individual making sense out of its own
motivations its own life its own
and then its own we might say today
narrative its own life story right and
he says it's aware of itself merely as
an individual and and such as an
individual it must demand and produce
its reality in another well that's that
double movement of self-consciousness we
don't have a self without having an
other self and when we do that there is
this destabilizing thing that happens
that we've seen play out if I am another
self to you then I and my freedom and my
perspective and my actions may run
counter to you that's a risk that you
have to take I'm not just a mere
duplicate of you if I was then you get
bored with me you would find it
insufficient you wouldn't get anything
out of that so we have to have a
relation to the other the other but the
other is another individual and so he
goes on and he says then however its
consciousness having raised itself into
universality it becomes universal reason
and as conscious of itself as reason as
a consciousness that is already this is
going a little bit further ahead right
recognized as in and for itself
implicitly not yet explicitly not at
this point but that's what it means to
grasp oneself not just as individual but
also as universal a great example of
this is in remorse when a person engages
in an action we're gonna see plenty of
this sort of thing happening in the next
sections a person engages in an action
which is an individual act and they
conceive of it as an individual act and
they don't think about the wider
implications on other people and they do
something that they know is in a certain
sense opposed to the universal opposed
to say society and its needs and they
act selfishly
now in the moment they may is we're
going to talk about pleasure and right
they may actually enjoy what's happening
and then they forget about it but then
later on their children ask them
something about it hey what's going on
in this picture are you doing this thing
that you tell me is not a good thing to
do because now the person is identified
with the universal at least in the
respect that they're telling their kids
not to do that sort of behavior and then
the parent feels oh man I'm providing a
bad example for this other person who is
taking me as an index that's actually
meaningful to them and then suddenly
they feel a sense of guilt or remorse or
repentance Metanoia right and they
become conscious of this conflict
running between the irreversible past
and the present where action is possible
where things can happen that's a feeling
of conflict between the individual and
the universal and that's the sort of
thing that's going to get worked out in
this this section so he goes on and he
says it is the simple spiritual essence
which in attaining consciousness is at
the same time real substance Hagel's
bringing this terms substance in again
in a way that you're going to see assume
some importance in the next paragraph so
I don't want to say too much about it
right now says into which the earlier
forms return is into their ground so
that means everything that was going on
in in the dialectic of consciousness in
all those paragraphs everything that was
going on in the dialectic of
self-consciousness is now being brought
into a higher more concrete unity or not
yet unity but at least a a place where
all these things are playing out now in
a more complex way so he says in
comparison with the latter income
harrison with what is happening up here
they are merely particular moments of
it's becoming moments which do indeed
break loose and appear as independent
forms you can study say the play of
perception by itself but you can also
understand it as integrated into this
much larger higher more meaningful more
dynamic systemic opposition duality
interplay between individuals who now
incorporate that into themselves so you
can have a dual perspective on what's
gone before in the phenomenology Hagel
is not saying that they have no meaning
whatsoever on its own you saying these
these moments do indeed break loose and
appear as independent forms but then he
says they do they in fact have existence
in reality only is grounded in that
becoming and possess their truth only
insofar as they are and remain in it so
you know they the previous forms the
previous guests Alton of consciousness
they do in fact exist on their own to
some degree when they become isolated
like that as if we are going to treat
sade construct an entire philosophical
anthropology or social theory or
metaphysics just on the basis of those
then they're going to start showing up
all sorts of problems that can't be
resolved at that level this is really
quite fascinating because what it has
the implication that all of this only
makes its full sense only has what
Hagel's calling its truth in this
respect within the scope of reason and
that's going to be later on within the
scope of spirit and ultimately absolute
knowing
if we take this goal and this is the
notion which for us has already appeared
on the scene in its reality that is the
self-consciousness that is recognized
and acknowledged in which has its own
self certainty and the other free self
consciousness and possesses its truth
precisely in that other in other words
if we look on this still inner spirit as
substance that has already advanced to
the stage of having an outer existence
then in this notion there is disclosed
the realm of ethical life for this is
nothing else than the absolute spiritual
unity of the essence of individuals and
their independent actual existence it is
an intrinsically Universal
self-consciousness that takes itself to
be actual in another consciousness in
such wise that this has complete
independence or is looked on as a thing
and it is precisely there in that the
universal self-consciousness is aware of
its unity with it and only in this unity
with this objective being is it self
consciousness this ethical substance
taken in its abstract universality is
only law in the form of thought but it
is no less immediately actual self
consciousness or it is custom the single
individual consciousness conversely is
only this existent unit insofar as it is
aware of the universal consciousness in
its individuality as its own being since
what it does and is is the universal
custom
here now in
our graph 349 Hagel is going to
introduce this term silly kite which
we're translating in the Miller
translation as ethical life and for good
reason this is a very important concept
running throughout not just you might
say hey galley and ethics or social
philosophy but through the entire hey
galleon system as a whole and it
frequently gets left out in
summarization of it except for the
people who are particularly interested
in Hagel for social theory now I want to
point something out from the very
beginning that I think will be helpful
to an english-speaking audience when
Hagel is talking about ethical life or
this this realm of the ethic hole right
zit lee kite and will sometimes counter
pose to it in certain places morality
morality at what we do in english when
people make distinctions between ethics
and morality is almost the exact
opposite we tend to view we tend we tend
to talk if we make that distinction and
by the way when it comes to the realm of
ethics it's not it's not a distinction
that's universally observed there's good
reasons to think that it things aren't
quite so simple is that but it tends to
be that we are morality is understood as
a set of codes that were not very
self-conscious about or reflective about
and then ethics is the discipline where
we look at these things very seriously
and rigorously so some things that may
be commanded or prohibited by morality
ethics may take a look at and say no no
there's no good reason for that no good
rational justification in the
translation of what Hagel is doing here
what we would typically in an Anglophone
context call FX is what he's calling
morali Tessa right so we'll tante is
doing and the people in enlightenment
are doing this rational
critical process of trying to construct
an ethics that can apply across the
board ever that's that's morality at
right and ethics bit ly k or the ethical
is going to be this less reflective more
customary we're seeing customers
translation of vitta here more grounded
in the society and its its ways of doing
things and it's you might say it's
traditions that is what we would
normally call morality but but here it's
being called ethic so you don't want to
get those two mixed up now Hagel starts
out by talking in this section about a
reality or I think we could even
translate this as realization is reality
tatts right but what we're talking about
is something that's not quite realized
yet something that's not quite made real
they say about this goal the notion that
the beginning of the concept in its its
reality he says if we take this goal
this is the notion which for us is
already appeared on the scene in its
reality what is that it's reality it is
a self consciousness that is recognized
and acknowledged is here that's a playa
Nazem the german just has honor Kent
right recognized by what where can you
get recognition for acknowledgement from
another self-consciousness so there has
to be another self-consciousness hear in
the mix and the relationship between
them is that of recognition as we saw in
in many of the previous dialectics this
recognition can sometimes be one sided
or not entirely complete so we're not
yet at the goal we're actually nowhere
near the goal but we're looking down the
line and seeing what the goal would be
what is it's driving us what the desire
is for the you know the hunger literally
the begir de so he says
self-consciousness that is recognized
and acknowledged which has
its own self certainty in the other free
self consciousness this is where we get
beyond something like the master-slave
dialectic or get beyond the withdrawal
from the world that we saw happening in
in stoicism and also in skepticism in
different ways or from the you know
dialectic involved in the unhappy
consciousness where the you know the
freedom was relocated into this beyond
but it wasn't really free and I'm free
but I'm not really free all of this this
sort of thing going on and even takes
place in the reason section in the owner
talking about psychological laws and my
freedom with respect to them here I can
only attain true recognition from
another self consciousness that is in
fact free if I attempt to compel or
coerce that recognition it's a
self-defeating action on my part you
know and we know this because we get
into fights with people and try to
compel them to recognize that we're
right and they do so solemnly and we're
not very happy with it there's a lot of
other ways in which this happens so he
stresses its own self certainty is in
the other self consciousness and it
possesses its truth precisely in that
other so we have here something that I
want to point out I've mentioned in the
past that we almost never in the
Hegelian dialectic get truth and self
certainty at the same time we often
start out with certainty and then we're
like well I wonder this certainty this
give his height this you know being
feeling confident about that is it
really the fullness of things is it
truth and then we go off pursuing truth
and we get our hands around the truth
and then we're like great now oh crap
where did the certainty go okay I'll
turn over this way and what I where is
that certainty we try to bring the truth
along with us and eventually in the
process we do reach a point where truth
and self certainty fuse together but
here's where it gets really interesting
we never do so as he galleons or even as
people following the Hegelian dialectic
for a while in a monadic monistic
solipsistic i run the show kind of way
it's always got to be with another self
consciousness or with a whole society
self-consciousness that's why that's the
goal that's not something we've actually
attained at this point but we can see it
far off as something that we're
hunkering for we're desiring and trying
to move towards Hagel thought that this
was eventually realized in what he
called you you know absolute knowing we
don't necessarily have to be committed
to that to understand what's going on at
this point so he talks now here's
another transition point about spirit
and substance and he says in other words
if we look on this still inner spirit
relation between the two
self-consciousness Azure a whole bunch
of self-consciousness as substance that
has already advanced to the stage of
having an outer existence then in this
notion there is disclosed the realm of
ethical life the right there's Italy
kite what does he mean by substance in
this case another way we could translate
that less literally of course because
the German is substance society when
we've reached the point where we have
social relations set up in such a way
that consciousnesses are not merely
confronting each other in some sort of
void in a prim eval battle to the death
but are running into each other day to
day and saying hey how are you and then
perhaps even listening to the other
person saying oh you know pretty good
but my such-and-such is happening this
way well then we actually have what's
called spiritual
substance and what we've got there is
society as a realm Hagel doesn't think
of societies as just a whole bunch of
aggregated individuals that have you
know no intrinsic relations to each
other know we exist within societies and
we have our identities in large part in
relation to those societies and in
relation to the other people who occupy
other roles within that society Hagel
that's that's his fundamental viewpoint
we can break out of that things can
collapse and turn into this atomistic
point of view sometimes that can even be
what we need like what happens during
the Enlightenment but for the most part
we exist within social matrices that
provide us with what he's calling the
the realm of ethical life now I didn't
go on and draw too much on the board to
characterize this in part because what
we're going to do in the next you know
how many hundred or so paragraphs is
talk about all the different facets and
ins and outs of this ethical life but we
do want to follow out a few things so I
notice there's a bunch of individuals
here this is a unity of individuals he
says this is nothing else than the
absolute spiritual unity of the essence
of individuals in their independent
actual existence and it talks here about
an intrinsically universal self
consciousness that takes itself to be
actual in another consciousness in such
a way that this has complete
independence or has looked at it as a
thing and it is precisely there in that
the universal self consciousness is
aware of its unity with it so in ethical
life in the day-to-day and also the
momentous you don't think about events
like birth death conflict you know
marriage all these sorts of important
transition points work you know in all
of this we have a universal
consciousness that is uniting all these
individuals and also related to these
individuals as well
it's probably not going to be entirely
conflict-free that's eventually you know
the goal right but we're going to work
towards that but it does connect them
together so he says only in these unity
with this objective being is
self-consciousness self-consciousness so
now it's not just that I'm a
self-consciousness only in relation to
another one other self-consciousness
like you know two people to Robinson
Caruso's encountering each other on the
desert island I'm really only a
self-consciousness fully within the
matrix of some sort of larger group some
community some community that has mores
or as it's going to be translated here
habits customs did that traditions we
might even say these might be ones that
get made up as they they work through
things and approach new issues and all
that but there's going to be something
exceeding the individual that provides a
universal consciousness that they can be
a part of and develop their self
consciousness in relationship so he goes
on and he says this ethical substance
taken in its abstract universality is
only law in the form of thought right
it's not yet explicit but it is no less
immediately self-consciousness or it is
Zetta custom when you feel the weight of
custom like for example I mean you may
think that you're totally liberated from
customs and I I'm a you know totally
rational reflexive person I don't buy
into what the man tells me to do or what
society expects of me and well that's
not true at all because that itself is
already you know a long tradition
whether you're modeling yourself after
you know this person or that person
you're taking some is a model there's
some other people that are saying to you
right on man or whatever you know all
their sort of equivalent that would be
counter cultural here's what I could say
the encounter cultural is always
cultural right and you're always drawing
and
that's good that's why you can find any
sort of satisfaction in it you know
because there's another at least one
other self consciousness even if just
one you've imagined yourself that's
giving you some Pat's on the back and
saying hey you can you matter I like
what you're doing that's important to us
as human beings so he says the single
individual consciousness is only this
exhibit this existent unit insofar as it
is aware of the universal consciousness
in its individuality as its own being
since what it does and is is the
universal custom now of course we can be
alienated from the universal custom in
all sorts of ways and we're going to
talk about this we can be problematizing
it and like i don't know which way I
should go as a matter of fact a good
part of our development of our life
consists in that sort of thing
adolescence is a period in which a lot
of people go through that unless they
you know have that resolved for them by
being told well you're going to work
right things like that happen in midlife
but for the most part we we internalize
what it is that we're learning from our
society and Hegel sees that is actually
not just losing ourselves or being
brainwashed he sees that as a necessary
component of the human development of a
self-consciousness
you